[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video i'm going to be discussing
those responsible for educating the
youth of the wizarding world
i am of course talking about the
professors of hogwarts
in the past i've made videos ranking the
most powerful slytherins
gryffindors hufflepuffs ravenclaws death
eaters
order of the phoenix members and even
auras you guys seem to really enjoy that
type of video
so today i'm going to be ranking the
most powerful professors
of hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry where i normally do the top
five
i felt that in this particular case the
top six would be more fitting
as many of the hogwarts professors are
in my opinion very evenly matched
i also want to mention that just because
a professor doesn't make this list
it doesn't mean that they aren't
powerful it just means that they are in
my opinion
not one of the six most powerful the
professors of hogwarts have arguably the
most important role in the entire
wizarding universe
as they are chiefly responsible for
educating the youth of the wizarding
world
without them witches and wizards would
have a much harder time developing in
honing their spells and abilities
you'd be hard pressed to argue that the
wizarding world doesn't need an
educational body
and they think that things would be far
worse without it similar to the
education system
in our own world it helps students
figure out what they're good at and
provides them with some guidance with
regards to a path
that they can follow additionally i
think that it's safe to say that the
professors of hogwarts go above and
beyond in their role as teachers
time and time again the hogwarts
professors have been shown to provide a
level of care
beyond what is traditionally expected of
a teacher-student relationship
not only that the professors of hogwarts
a lot of them anyway
are extremely talented witches and
wizards that could be doing any
multitude of jobs
but instead they remain at hogwarts so
that they can impart some of their
knowledge
onto the next generation so who you may
ask
is the most powerful of these noble
figures let's dive into it
number six remus lupin remus lupin was a
british half-blood wizard
born in the year 1960. like most others
he attended hogwarts
and it was there that he befriended the
other members of the marauders james
potter
sirius black and peter pettigrew lupin
had a rough start to his life
as before he'd even begun attending
hogwarts he was attacked in his home by
the notorious werewolf
fenrir greyback fenrir sought revenge on
remus father
lyle and his best way to get back at
lyle was to attack his son
remus was attacked by fenrir in the
middle of the night and though his life
was spared
being bitten meant that he was destined
to be a werewolf for the rest of his
life
his friends were fortunately very
understanding of his condition
but it certainly made his life hard as
there is an incredible amount of stigma
towards werewolves in the wizarding
world
after keeping a low profile for many
years remus returns to hogwarts as an
adult in the 93-94 school year
it's in the same year that remus accepts
a position to teach defense against the
dark arts
remus was a very talented wizard and
like the other marauders
was able to accomplish quite a lot
magically at a very young age
among other things remus was a talented
duelist having escaped the battle of the
department of mysteries unscathed
a charms expert having helped to create
the marauders map
a practitioner of healing magic having
effectively used a bandaging charm on
ron
a defense against the dark arts expert
having successfully taught a class on it
at hogwarts
and even an accomplished oklahomans not
only that but remus was sort of a double
threat
because if he turned into a werewolf he
was a force to be reckoned with
remus was eventually killed by antonin
dolohov but he is arguably one of the
most powerful death eaters
so he definitely didn't go out easy and
i think that he's certainly worthy of a
spot
on this list number five philia
splitwick
vlitwick was born in the year 1958 and
began attending hogwarts in the year
1969.
flipwick had always valued intelligence
which meant that his personality
was very much in alignment with the
house that he'd been assigned to
during his time at the school flipback
achieved high grades in all of his owls
and mutes
particularly in the subject of charms
something that he was particularly
talented at
flitwick became the resident charms
master at hogwarts and head of ravenclaw
house
which seems fitting given that he has
been described as one of the best and
most knowledgeable charms masters alive
in the world today despite his small
stature flipwick is a force to be
reckoned with and it has been expressed
that after graduating from hogwarts
flitwick went on to become a master
duelist and dueling champion
he supposedly has a shelf full of
trophies to prove it flitwick had a high
level of knowledge in defense against
the dark arts
and during the battle of hogwarts he was
personally responsible for the defeat
of a handful of death eaters flitbick
also helped in putting up the defenses
around hogwarts which kept the death
eaters at bay for an extended period of
time
the defenses around the castle were of
course the result of flipbrick's charm
work
which was the area of magic that he was
most skilled in litwick is thought to be
one of the most talented charms teachers
that ever taught at hogwarts
and had no difficulty producing even the
most complex complicated
and powerful shield charms flitwick
could also produce a patronus which is
the mark of a powerful wizard
in addition to dueling and charms
blipwick was also versed in
transfiguration
and conjuration and was able to conjure
objects out of thin
air i have no doubt in my mind that
philosophic is deserving of a spot on
this list
number four horus slughorn horus
slughorn is an english pure blood wizard
born sometime between 1882
and 1913. when he attended hogwarts as a
boy he was sorted into slytherin house
and because he embodied many aspects of
slytherin house he embraced it
when he was older he even became head of
the house a role given to one individual
responsible
for looking after and disciplining the
students of the house
given slytherin's reputation for
producing dark witches and wizards
this role took someone with a firm hand
and though cyclone can seem quite
aloof at times he's incredibly sharp and
even more powerful
when you think of a powerful wizard
slughorn doesn't exactly come to mind
and that's mainly because of his
character however beneath his more
inviting surface
slogan is actually very determined
resourceful and cunning
much like salazar slithering himself in
addition to being head of slytherin
house
slughorn also worked as potions master
at hogwarts
an incredibly technical role that was
also notably held by severus snape
potions require a great deal of patience
and wisdom two things that cyclone
certainly had
but his knowledge didn't stop in a realm
of potions slughorn's most notorious
action to date was certainly the moment
that he provided a young tom riddle with
the integral information he needed on
horcruxes
this was a shifting point for the
wizarding world as it allowed a dark and
sinister wizard to effectively become
immortal however i have always found it
impressive that slughorn knew about
horcraxes to begin with
as seemingly no one else did sarkorn is
widely considered to be talented
but i think that he's a bit of a sleeper
and that he is even more powerful than
he lets on in the battle of hogwarts
slughorn even engages the dark lord head
on with mcgonagall and kingsley
proving himself a masterful duelist even
the ever arrogant lucius malfoy who
would never pay anyone a compliment
told draco that suggorn was a good
wizard my father always said he was a
good wizard in his day
slughorn's magical arsenal is vast and
he exhibited an extreme level of
knowledge
power in the following disciplines
occlumency dueling
potions non-verbal magic charms defense
against the dark arts
dark arts and even piano playing number
three
minerva mcgonagall minerva mcgonagall is
a scottish half blood witch
that attended hogwarts school of
witchcraft of wizardry and later worked
there
while she attended hogwarts she was the
most talented student of her entire year
and she achieved top grades in her newts
and owls she accepted extreme magical
prowess from a very young age and laid
to become one of hogwarts best
professors
mcgonagall's most notable skill is
perhaps related to her knowledge and
talent
and transfiguration she is known for her
effortless ability to transform
her physical form which is particularly
impressive given how dangerous
transfiguration
can be transfiguration is some of the
most complex and dangerous magic
you will learn at hogwarts anyone
messing around in my class will leave
and not come back you have been warned
mcgonagall was extremely proficient at
transfiguration
even in her school days becoming an
animagus at a very young age after acing
both her owls and mutes in the subject
she later became head of transfiguration
at hogwarts a position that she took
very seriously
mcgonagall was also highly proficient at
casting a wide variety of charms
and mastered the patronus charm in both
corporeal and incorporeal forms
when she was still very young she was
also a skilled potion maker
able to successfully brew an animagus
potion and duelist notably dueling lord
voldemort to a standstill
alongside slughorn and kingsley what
makes mcgonagall particularly powerful
is her paired knowledge of the dark arts
not only did she master charms
transfiguration dueling and potion
making
she also had a vast knowledge of the
dark arts though she didn't use dark
spells frequently
she could use them when necessary and
notably used the imperial's curse on
amicus cara
one of mcgonagall's most impressive
abilities a lot of people don't know
about
is her ability to manipulate the
elements similar to dumbledore
it has been expressed that like
dumbledore mcgonagall could manipulate
fire and ice
number two severus snape snape was born
on january 9th
1960 to a muggle father to buy a snape
and which mother
eileen prince and grew up on a street
called spinner's end
in the muggle town of coke worth one
thing that i want to mention right out
of the gate
is that snape is one of the most
powerful wizards in the wizarding world
and what was most impressive about him
is that he wasn't even that old when he
died
snape died at the tender age of 38 and
though he wasn't quite at the level of
voldemort or dumbledore
he was getting there throughout the
series time and time again
snape showcases spells and abilities
that are difficult to conjure
and often unique he's also a
well-rounded wizard because he was never
afraid of venturing
into experimentation with dark arts he
knows the good spells
and more sinister spells he knows it all
snape is a testament to what can be
achieved if you're really dedicated to
something
as a student snape always had his head
in the books continually learning and
progressing
he was focused and he didn't let
temporary satisfaction get in the way of
achieving more
learning more though he had a segue down
a dark path the result of bullying
and the loss of his friendship with lily
snape only used his hatred for the
marauders as fuel
it gave him the drive and the motivation
to be more to do more
during his time at hogwarts snape
assumed the identity the half-blood
prince
and scribbled all sorts of spell
creations into his copy of advanced
potion making
among these spells was the powerful and
vicious sectim's emperor
the snape can also fly and is one of
only two known wizards who are capable
of doing this
the other being voldemort snape was the
dada professor
potions professor and even hogwarts
headmaster for a period
and given his level of power he was an
extremely valuable asset to hogwarts
had he been around for a few decades
longer i think that snape may just have
had a shot at being most powerful wizard
ever number one albus dumbledore
surprise surprise dumbledore is number
one once again but the truth is
he is number one he's the number one
gryffindor the number one order of the
phoenix member
and now the number one hogwarts
professor but that reputation was well
earned
dumbledore's magical prowess became
apparent from a very young age
and while at school dumbledore's magical
abilities consistently turned heads
particularly his skills surrounding
charms and transfiguration
he also did exceptionally well on his
newts and griselda marchbanks a
professor working for the wizarding
examinations authority remarked that
albus was able to do things with the
wand that she had never seen before
in addition to being a charms and
transfiguration master domino was also
an expert practitioner of elemental
magic
over the course of the books and films
he's really shown us what he's capable
of
and in his jewel against voldemort in
the ministry atrium we see his elemental
expertise shine through
when he creates some sort of complicated
hydrokinetic spell
i think that his most impressive display
of magic was when he produced a
firestorm toward off the inferi
firestorm produces a large ring of fire
from the caster's wand
and from this ring the caster is able to
shoot jets or balls of fire at opponents
dumbledore also defeated grindelwald the
dark force that threatened the wizarding
world before voldemort
and whether he had help or not he is
credited as doing it i really don't
think that you can question
his level of power there truly isn't a
subject or area of magic where
dumbledore is lacking
he knows transfiguration conjuration
charms potions elemental magic
occlumency the list goes on
the only way that dumbledore could have
become more powerful is if he delved
into the dark arts but as mcgonagall put
it
dumbledore was too noble to do that and
that's it for my list of the most
powerful hogwarts professors
it's also worth noting that i excluded
moody as he never actually taught
he was captured and impersonated by
barty crouch jr before the school year
even started
so he was not an actual hogwarts
professor if the real moody actually
taught
he may have made this list what do you
guys think of this list what are your
rankings
let me know in the comment section below
until next time
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
[Music]
you